hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from yesterday's title Tuesday
a lot of you guys have requested this
one and for very good reasons uh Magnus
Carlsen was able to play a bullet game
uh with an accuracy of 98.1 percent now
to put this into perspective this is uh
this is a lot even uh for a rapid game
or even for a classical game if you if
you played a classical game not on uh
maybe not like a Berlin uh defense game
where okay you play 25 moves of known
Theory and then you agree to a draw okay
maybe you can play with 98.1 accuracy
but with a crazy game like this with one
minute on the clock not something that
happens every day so let's check it out
vidit has the white pieces and he opened
with the D4 Magnus win Knight to F6 with
C for C5 uh Pawn to D5 advancing the
pawn against the benoni and now Ponte G6
with Knight to C3 Bishop to G7 and now
Pawn to E4 with Bishop Pawn to D6 and
now many moves are possible here in
Knight to F3 and Bishop to D3 are the
popular once you can go H3 you can you
can go for the four pawns attack with F4
if it goes for Bishop to E2 and now
Castles by Magnus we have Knight to F3
E6 and now Castle so this is all very
standard stuff E Capture C captures Rook
d8 you put pressure on the uh E4 pawn
and now Knight the D2 is the move uh
that you have to play if you play this
as white
now the pawn is nicely defended you can
solidify with F3 and the Knight might
come even the C4 to put further pressure
on that D6 Pawn so we have Knight to A6
the Knight will be re-maneuvered to C7
it's the standard idea uh we have King
to H1 before opening up this diagonal
you might run into trouble later on if
you don't play this and now Knight the
C7 we have Pawn to F3 Pawn to B6 by
Magnus and now Pawn to A4 we have rooked
a B8 and now Knights the C4 the Knight
is excellently placed here as if it has
a great control over the B5 Square so
you don't have to worry about that
Knight being kicked away with Bishop to
A6 and Bishop to G5 pinning the F6
Knight Bishop captures and C for this
Knight is a monster here and your light
Square Bishop isn't really all that
great so you are very happy to trade it
of course the ship captures Bishop
captures and now Pawn to A6 preparing to
further Advance the B Pawn uh Queen to
B3 adding more more Firepower to the B5
square and now Queen to C8 with Bishop
to F4 now putting pressure on that the
D6 Pawn now as it is undefended and now
the usually everyone plays Bishop death
8 here as it is a known position but
Magnus played Rook to d8 and it is now
as of move 18 that we have a completely
new game so like I said in the beginning
of the video yes we do get a lot of
theory but also uh it's a fairly long
game a very complicated one so the the
accuracy stands for itself we have Pawn
to G4 uh with it now uh wants the start
his expansion and the King said also he
wants to have G5 ready to kick away the
Knight if needed but one thing that the
G4 does it it it does weaken the white
king now this diagonal has been weakened
and the Magnus contrast this by playing
Queen to B7 and also it will give
additional support to the push of B5 so
we have Queen to C2 and now Pawn to B5
we have eight characters eight
characters Bishop goes back to E2 and
now while you do really like your queen
and B7 Magnus improves it even a bit
more he plays Queen to B6 this stops
with its idea of Rook A5 just going
after that B5 Pawn so Knight to D1 now
the Knight can be re-maneuvered you can
go Knight E3 you can go Knight to F2 to
D3 and then maybe later on push E5 uh
Knight to D7 also a standard idea and
the banon you want to play C4 and free
up that C5 Square for your knight we
have Knight to F2 Now Pawn to C4 we have
Rook a to D1 and now Rook to A8 as with
its Rook left FDA file magnus's Rook now
claims it we have Pawn to B3 also very
principle do you wanna uh go after that
uh C4 pawn and trade down if possible
but Magnus just advances it and now that
it does not want to lap onto B4 by
Magnus so he plays Ponte B4 himself we
have okay Rook to A4 now Magnus will
pile up on the a B for pawn and with it
needs to be ready to defend at Knight to
D3 and now Knights to A6 just putting
more pressure on the pawn and also Rook
is coming to C8 and then the C4 to put
even more pressure on that B4 Pawn so as
usual everything revolves around the B4
Square we have Queen to B3 Rook to C8
and now Rook the C1 uh we have rooked
the C4 putting pressure on the pawn here
and there's really no good way to add
another Defender to the B4 Pawn so if it
defends with a tactic Rook to A1 now the
idea behind Rook day one is that you
can't really start collecting pawns
because if Knight captures on B4 Rook
captures an A4 wins the game for with it
now if B captures the rook and C4 is
undefended Magnus really here has to
decide whether he wants to play Rook
captures on A1 or does he maybe even
want to sacrifice the exchange for two
connected pass pawns now it looks uh too
good to pass up on but the Magnus uh
gives the correct assessment because if
you if you actually go for this Knight
captures and now Rook captures yes you
do have the past pawns but it it's not
easy to start pushing them look at this
rookie and queen A3 goes after the
Knight and once the Knight is defended
or moved then you go Queen A5 you win
more space and after Queen to B8 you
will play roket to B1 and it's not easy
to connect to those pawns also the queen
is stuck here guarding the D6 Pawn this
would actually be very good for white so
Magnus assesses the position correctly
he plays Rook characters on A1 Rook
captures an A1 and now he goes for
Knight captures on B4 and now Vegeta
takes on B4 the only way to hold the
position is to try Knight to E1 and it
doesn't even hold it just uh you know
maybe allows Magnus uh more uh more
opportunities to make bad moves but
still after G5 it's just crushing uh you
have to play something Bishop captures
and G5 now Queen comes to F2 you put
pressure on the bishop and after Bishop
captures and C4 you will play B captures
and C4 and that's it there's no good
move for uh the White Queen if you
capture on B4 then of course Queen to F1
is checkmate that's just a maiden one
they're gonna have to play Queen
captures and see for the guard against
mate but now Pawn to C2 the pawn is
nicely defended here so you cannot touch
it and have to Rook the C1 Bishop to B2
is all that is needed to win this game
so that's the problem for vivid here so
if you play Knight captures on B4 and
now Magnus goes for Queen to F2 he puts
pressure on the bishop here and again
you could capture The Rook but then you
just run into a devastating Checkmate
Queen captures an F3 check King G1
Bishop to D4 check uh in the no more
moves for the white king you have to
block and then Bishop captures on E3
will be a very nice Checkmate here with
the queen and Bishop cutting off the
white king completely so after Queen to
F2 will it found a nice defensive idea
he played Rook to A2 but again the
position is completely winning for
Magnus but you have to find a very
particular idea only one move wins the
game for Magnus so feel free to pause
the video and find it while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finishing this
98.1 uh Masterpiece uh accuracy
Masterpiece and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show the move is
Bishop to D4 for those of you who are
who played the benoni or or the bank or
you are no stranger to the devastating
power of the uh you know potential
Bishop to D4 moves but of course if you
don't then you might have just found it
all on your own so Bishop to D4
threatens Queen to G1 Checkmate and now
there's no good way to defend Queen to
D1 was played okay you stopped Checkmate
but now the Knight on B4 really is
hanging so Rook captures on B4 Magnus
wins material Bishop to G3 if it played
a few more moves Queen E3 we have Bishop
captures and D6 attacking The Rook but
now just to Rook the B2 absolutely every
move Magnus played is a top engine move
uh and you just cannot play against that
real characters on B2 C captures and now
Bishop to D3 guarding the queening
square but now Queen to C1 and he was in
this position on move 39 that video
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here if you do nothing
then you lose the queen if you take the
queen then of course you get another
queen into the game uh and if you like
defend the queen then you a Magnus can
simply bring another queen into the game
play Queen capture Sandy one on the next
move and he is just up too much material
uh so there we have it that's what uh
what a 98.1 accuracy bullet game looks
like uh like I said yeah I I I I I would
be I would be ecstatic if I was able to
play a third a 40 move uh classical game
with a 98.1 accuracy but when it's a
bullet then it's just it's just
completely unreal so there we have it
that's how Magnus plays but even with
all this he was not able to win the
tournament although he got a clear
second place the tournament Was Won uh
by the Dmitry and Drake and he had half
a point ahead of uh he was a half a
point ahead of Magnus Carlsen and he uh
won his 15th title Tuesday so incredibly
incredible event for him uh so yeah
that's the game really hope you guys can
enjoy that you know you have to uh you
know know a lot of theory and you know
have a really good day in order to be
able to pull off something like this so
you know keep trying I would like to
thank Amanda Oliver the most beautiful
girl in the world the Duncan wine called
egbertian shirkhorn olive oil and Adam
Decker the loneliest single guy in the
world for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day